[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم قال اذا وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي مشوشي علون ان المعركه
ضد حماس سوف تتوسع وتستهدف البنى التحتيه
للحركه خلال الايام القليله القادمه وقد
سبق لاسرائيل ان شنت عده حروب على حركه
حماس رسمت لها اهدافا عديده في مقدمتها
تدمير بنيتها التحتيه وشل قدرات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على اطلاق الصواريخ تجاه المدن
الاسرائيليه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل يختلف هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
عن اخر حربين شنته اسرائيل على غزه عامي
الف 2008
و22 وهل يمكن لهذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي ان
يفضي الى صياغه جديده للمشهد بين اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
والفلسطينيين قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
مشي علون ان العمليه العسكريه على قطاع
غزه سوف تستمر اياما عديده وطويله ولن
تنتهي الا بعد بعد ان تدفع حركه حماس ثمنا
غاليا على حد تعبيره العمليه التي خلفت
حتى الان عشرات القتلى من الفلسطينيين
ومئات الجرحى تهدف وفقه تلبيب الى اضعاف
قدرات المقاومه وحمايه امن المواطنين
الاسرائيليين استخدم الاحتلال نفس الحجه
خلال حربين سابقتين على غزه دون تحقيق اي
انتصار ما وجه الشبه اذا والاختلاف بين
العمليه الع العسكريه الراهنه وحربي
و22 تسميها اسرائيل ما شاءت في النهايه هي
حرب اخرى على
غزه فعلتها من قبل في 2008 وفي
2012 في كل مره يكون الهدف المعلن هو ضرب
قدرات المقاومه الفلسطينيه داخل القطاع
بحجه حمايه امن المواطنين الاسرائيليين
لكنها هذه المره تتفادى مصطلح الحرب وتقول
انها عمليه عسكريه ستدوم اياما عديده
وطويله ما وجه الاختلاف بين هذه الموجه
الجديده من الاعتداءات الحاليه لجيش
الاحتلال على القطاع والهجمات السابقه
الفرق قد يكمن في الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
المتبعه حاليا وسط خشيه من التوغل البري
الذي تريد اسرائيل تفاديه فشلت في الحربين
السابقتين في في القضاء على المقاومه
لماذا اذا هذه الحرب وفي هذا
التوقيت ربما لاضعاف المقاومه واستنزاف
مخزونها قبل اي اتفاق جديد لوقف اطلاق
النار او حتى خلق واقع داخلي فلسطيني
مغاير فالمصالح بين فتح وحماس لم ولن
تراها اسرائيل ابدا بعين الرضا بالرغم من
اختلاف الظروف الاقليميه لهذه الحرب لا
يتوقع ان تحقق اسرائيل ما فشلت في ان في
الحربين السابقتين على قطاع غزه تطوير
انظمه دفاعها لاعتراض صواريخ المقاومه لم
يمنع سقوط صواريخ كتائب القسام لاول مره
على جنوب حيفا استهدفت صواريخ اخرى تل
ابيب لم تقتل تلك الصواريخ اي اسرائيلي
بيد ان غارات جيش الاحتلال والتي تجاوزت
المئات خلال يومين قتلت عشرات الفلسطينيين
وبينهم نساء واطفال ودمرت بيوت مدنيين
اصيب المئات ايضا بجروح متفاوته قد تختلف
تكتيكات سلطه وجيش الاحتلال ولكن نتائج
اعتداءاتها على اهالي غزه هي دائما موت
وخراب وصمت دولي
مخجل موضوع حلقتنا هذا اذا نناقشه مع
ضيوفنا حيث ينضم الينا من رام الله
الدكتور حسام زملط استاذ العلوم
الاستراتيجيه وينضم الينا من القدس الكاتب
الصحفي روني شاكيد وينضم الينا من واشنطن
الكاتب الصحفي سعيد رقات نرحب بضيوفنا
جميعا وابدا مع رام الله والدكتور حسام
زملط دكتور حسام يعني نحن الان امام اجواء
حرب
حقيقيه اليوم تشن اسرائيل حربا على غزه
قبلها عام
201 ايضا شنت حربا على غزه وقبلها عام
2008 شنت حربا على غزه هل هذه الحرب اليوم
استنساخ للحرب السابقتين
برايك
لا جديد حقيقه في التعامل الاسرائيلي مع
غزه مع الضفه مع القدس في كل مكان دعني
استهل هذا البرنامج اختي خديجه ليتمنى
السلامه لاهلنا وشعبنا الفلسطيني في كل
مكان فالمقصود والهدف هو كل الشعب
الفلسطيني اي نعم يتعرض اهلنا في غزه الى
اشنى عمليه واكثرها عنفا الان ولكن الجميع
يتعرض حتى بما فيه الشعب الفلسطيني في
داخل الارض الفلسطينيه المحتله عام
1948 وردا على سؤالك الجديد في هذه الحمله
الاسرائيليه حقيقه الاخيره انها تتعدى
ارهاب الدوله الذي حصل قبل ذلك كان ارهاب
دوله منظم من قبل اسرائيل خلال عام 19
2008 و212 ولكن الان ما تفعله اسرائيل
يرتقى يرتقي بالمعنى القانوني الى الاباده
الجماعيه عندما تستقصي قتل اعداد كبيره من
المدنيين بدون تفريق وبهذا الشيء وبهذا
المشهد الذي شاهدناه على كل شاشات العالم
هذا يعرف كابا جماعيه وجرائم ضد الانسانيه
ودعنا نضع اختي خديجه هذا الموضوع في
اطاره الاعم والاشمل حتى نفهم الصوره
الحقيقيه التي تجري اسرائيل وما وما تفعله
له اطار ذات ثلاث اضلاع الضلع الاول الضلع
الاول ايديولوجي عقائدي حقيقه هذا هذا هذا
الضلع وهذا المستوى العقائدي الذي يحتقر
الا الاخر ويجعل من دم اليهودي مختلف عن
دم البشريه الاخرى هذا هذا التحريض
المستمر لسنوات عديده الذي يتحمله نتنياهو
وحكومته بالشكل الاكبر هو الذي صنع هذه
اله الحقد والكراهيه
الشديده ح نعم لهذه الحرب دعني فقط اطرح
نفس السؤال على بقيه الضيوف سيد روني شكيد
نسخه هذه الحرب نسخه مكرره لحربي 2008
20112 مع كل الاسا اول شيء رمضان كريم مع
كل الاسف لازم اقول الشيء اللي صار هو
اللي بيصير بالايام هدول شرا ولازم نفهم
شيء كبير ولازم اقول بصوت عالي اذا على
قطر كان كل يوم ينزلوا 60 او 70 او 80
صاروخ وينزلوا على السكان اللي بروحوا
واحد بروح للبستان واحد بيروح للمدرسه
واحد بروح لغير محل هذا انا ما بعرف اذا
كان كانوا يسكتوا هناك نفس الشيء كان سنه
2008 نفس الشيء 2010 نفس الشيء المراه هذه
انا ما بفكر ان اسرائيل بدها تساوي حرب مع
مع في غزه و ما بدها انه انه تسقط حماس هي
بدها انه حماس
توقف الصواريخ تبعها تجاه المدن في
اسرائيل هذا السبب اللي صارت الحرب بالمره
هذه نفس الشيء اللي صار في سنه 2008 وسنه
2010 هذا مش شي
تقصد نفس الاسباب نفس الطريق نفس الاسباب
نفس واللي بدفع الثمن بدفع الثمن حت ا كل
واحد منكم حقه من الوقت استاذ سعيد عريقات
نفس الاسباب وبالتالي نفس ال النسخ تتكرر
من هذه
الحرب ا بدايه نتمنى على شعبنا في في غزه
الصمود كما عودنا على ذلك ونتمنى لعائلات
القتلى والجرحى نتمنى لهم تعازينا الحاره
وللجرحى التعافي الكامل والسريع انا اعتقد
انه ليس هناك جديد هذه هي الحلقه الاخيره
من نفس الحرب التي تشنها اسرائيل على كل
الفلسطينيين منذ عام 48 وحتى اليوم فليس
هناك جديد حقيقه اسرائيل بين الفتره
والفتره تركز قواها الهائله وتضرب باغلبيه
شعب عازل لا يستطيع الدفاع عن نفسه تحت
حجه ان حركه حماس او الحركات الفلسطينيه
الاخرى تملك صواريخ وتضرب وكما ذكر السيد
من القدس هذه الذريعه التي تتشدق بها سواء
الا الداره الامريكيه او اسرائيل تحت هذه
الذريعه ان الناس يعانون من الهلع ومن
الخوف ومن الضرب وانهم لا يستطيعون الذهاب
الى المدارس ماذا عن الحصار القائم سنه
بعد سنه ماذا عن الاحتلال القائم سنه بعد
سنه ماذا عن الاستيطان الذي يستشري سنه
بعد سنه هذه القضايا الاساسيه التي يجب
معالجتها وليس القول اننا لسنا في حرب مع
مع حماس قد يكون هذا صحيح لانها اسرائيل
حقيقه هي في حاله حرب مستمر مع الشعب
الفلسطيني لنكران عليه لنكران عليه ابسط
حقوقه الانسانيه طيب دكتور حسام زملط ربما
هناك متغيرات سواء على الساحه الداخليه
الفلسطينيه او حتى على الساحه الدوليه
والاقليميه على المستوى الداخلي هناك
حكومه وفاق فلسطيني على المستوى الخارجي
هناك وضع عربي متغير
هناك التغيير الذي حصل في مصر وبالتالي
حماس فقدت ربما السند الاساسي لها كل هذه
المتغيرات كيف اثرت على مسار هذه الحرب
هذه المره على عكس ما كان في السابق في
الحروب
السابقه هي سبب اساسي للحرب هذه المتغيرات
التي ذكرتيها اختي خديجه واهم هذه
المتغيرات هي حكومه الوفاق الوطني
الفلسطيني عوده غزه الى العمق الفلسطيني
بدايه الطريق نحو وحده فلسطينيه حقيقيه
هذا ازعج اسرائيل لان استراتيجيتها خلال
السنوات الكثيره السابقه كانت تعتمد على
اساس تشتيت المجتمع الفلسطيني والشعب
الفلسطيني وقضيته وتحويلها الى مجتمعات
وقبائل واضعاف كل ممثلين الشعب الفلسطيني
السياسيين اما في غزه او في الضفا او في
الشتات وهذا جلى في الاسابيع الاخيره حيث
بداوا بحمله كبيره مسعوره في الضفه قبل ان
ينتقلوا الى غزه وجاءت هذه المصالحه لتقسم
هذا الحساب الاسرائيلي الاستراتيجي من
الظهر وتعيد غزه الى المعادله بشكل قوي
وتمكن الفلسطيني من ان يمثل قضيته بشكل
واحد ولشعب واحد ومطالب واحده وهذا كان
السبب الاساسي في تقديري لحرب نتنياهو لان
هذا لا لا يعجبه وبالتاكيد ايضا الابعاد
التي ذكرتيها هذا هذا الوضع في المنطقه
الكل مشغول بهذه الثورات والتغيرات
اسرائيل تستغل هذا الحدث والوضع الدولي
بشكل عام ال لاعم هذه نقطه مهمه للنقاش
سيد روني شكيد هل تستغل فعلا اسرائيل هذا
هذه المتغيرات
لصالحها تشن هذه الحرب على
غزه في هذا
الوقت لا بالعكس ليش لا لا وبالعكس انا
بقول لا في صوت عالي لانه لانه اذا كانت
اسرائيل بدها تستعمل الظروف هول الظروف
هدول كانت تستعملها من زمان مش من اليوم
من قبل سنه المشكله انه حماس اليوم ما
عندها علاقه مع مصر ما عندها علاقه مع
سوريا ما عندها علاقه بالدول العربيه شوفي
شو شو بيصير مع حماس بالنسبه للمصاري
بالنسبه للحال الاقتصادي اللي موجود هناك
كل شي موجود هلقيت اسرائيل لا لا بالعكس
اسرائيل ما بد الشيء هذا اليوم لما صرت
الحرب امبارح لما لما
تفجرت ان انفاق قدام كيرم شلوم معبر كيرم
شلوم اليوم دخلت لغزه 160 شحنات مع اكل مع
كل شيء اللي كان بزمه في غزه دخلت لغزه
هذا مش مش مش السبب والوحده الوطنيه اللي
بيحكوها اليوم مع كل الاسف ما بدي اضحك هل
في وحده وطنيه فلسطينيه بين
حماس وبين رام الله وبين ابو مازن لا احنا
عارفين الشي هذا عارفين ليش صارت الشي هذا
لا يمكن تنك معلشش
ي يم انكار ان اسرائيل فشلت اسرائيل فشلت
في منع تشكيل حكومه التوافق الفلسطيني
اسرائيل فشلت س اعطيك المجال للرد اسرائيل
فشلت في استخباراتيا في قضيه المستوطنين
الثلاثه في الخليج اسرائيل فشلت في منع
الاعتراف الاوروبي بالحكومه الفلسطينيه
والتعامل الامريكي معها يعني اسرائيل فشلت
في كل هذه
الامور اسرائيل ما ما فشلت لانه اسرائيل
ما كان بدا انه يكون حكومه
بين بين ابو مازن
وبين وبين وبين وبين حماس واذا اسرائيل
كانت تستنى كمان شهر بدون ما تحكي ولا
كلمه ما كان ولا شي احنا عارفين شو
شو العلاقات موجوده الي بالنسبه للخليل
احن عارفين شو صار هناك بالنسبه للثلاثه
المستوطنين شو نساوي اذا انقتل هل اسرائيل
كان لازم توقف ما تسوي ولا اي شي برضه
اسرائيل مش انبياء في اسرائيل في اوقات
اللي في فشل في اسرائيل اما هذا مش سبب
الحرب اللي موجود بالايام هدول لانه
الصواريخ اللي بتنزل في اسرائيل ولا دوله
بالعالم كانت تعطي
تكون مستعده انه ينزلوا صواريخ على الارض
تبعه بدون ما يكون رد في برضه بالقانون
الام
المتحده ل في في شي زي هيك ممكن يكون را
سنعود لنطرح مساله قوه الردعه الاسرائيليه
في القضاء على المقاومه وعلى اطلاق هذه
الصواري من غزه ولكن اطرح السؤال الذي
طرحته عليما على الاستاذ سعيد عريقات هل
استغلت اسرائيل هذه المتغيرات
الداخليه اقليميه لتشن هذه الحرب على غزه
في هذا
التوقيت بكل تاكيد اسرائيل تستغل الظروف
التي تسنح وهناك فرصه سانحه باستمرار خاصه
في ضوء الانشغال العربي عما يجري في
فلسطين وعن معاناه الشعب الفلسطيني هذا لا
يعني ان اسرائيل لم تخطط على المدى الطويل
لضرب اي حكومه وفاق وطني اسرائيل اعربت عن
انزعاجها من هذه الحكومه منذ اليوم الاول
وعملت على تقويضها ايضا منذ اليوم الاول
وصرحت ذلك علنا وقالت على عباس ان يختار
بين حماس وبين السلام مع العلم اننا خذنا
تجربه اخيرا لمده تسعه اشهر دون ان يتحقق
سلام دون ان تتقدم اسرائيل قيد انمله دون
ان تتراجع عن تعنتها دون ان تقدم شيء وهو
ما قاله بالمناسبه ممثل الرئيس الامريكي
يوم امس في مؤتمر السلام الاسرائيلي قالها
بصراحه اسرائيل لا تريد السلام اسرائيل لا
تعطي الشعب الفلسطيني كرامته اسرائيل تمعن
في اهانه الفلسطينيين لا تريد ان تحدد
حدودها لا تريد ان توقف الاستيطان اذا
هناك سياسه ممنهجه لاسرائيل تقوم على ان
لا يعطى المواطن الفلسطيني ابسط حقوقه
خاصه حقه في تقرير المصير فهي تستغل
الظروف نعم كما ذكر ضيفك من القدس تستغل
ظروف ان هناك ربما شعور بالعزله
من قبل حماس في علاقاتها مع مصر او مع
سوريا او مع غيرها وبالتالي هي دائما
تستغل هذه الفرصه وهي القوه
الاكبر وتحاول تقويض وضرب اي محاوله سواء
سياسيه او من نواحي اخرى لمقاومه الاحتلال
وتحقيق الاستقلال للشعب الفلسطيني دكتور
حسام زملط يعني في الحروب السابقه 2008
2012 وايضا في هذه الحرب السبب معلن
اسرائيليا هو منع اطلاق صواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من غزه ما مدى واقعيه هذه
الاسباب في يعني تفجير حرب كل سنتين ثلاث
سنوات اي خبير عسكري وانا ليست خبيرا
عسكريا سيرد عليك فورا ويقول ان هذا الهدف
لا يمكن تحقيقه فحماس او اي فصيل فلسطيني
يمكن له ان يطلق صاروخا صغيرا بعد ان يعلن
نتنياهو انتهاء الحرب وتكون بذلك حماس او
اي جهه اخرى انتصرت في هذه الحرب اذا كان
الهدف انهاء اطلاق الصواريخ وانهاء البنيه
التحتيه للفصائل الفلسطينيه هذا غير معقول
وجربته اسرائيل كما ذكرتي في العامين 2008
و2012 ولم يحصل الهدف الاساسي سياسي هذا
انتقام سياسي من الشعب الفلسطيني انتقام
سياسي على نجاحه في تشكيل على الاقل بدايه
لمصالحه وتشكيل حكه حكومه وفاق انتقام على
تمكن الشعب الفلسطيني من ان يخوض معارك
سياسيه وقانونيه ودبلوماسيه احرجت اسرائيل
هي غير مرتاحه هذه الحكومه اليمينيه حكومه
الاستيطان التي فيها اكثر من ست مستوطنين
في الكابينت غير مرتاحه ابدا على المربعات
الدبلوماسيه هي مرتاحه في المربع العسكري
والامني هذا هو مربع الذين يستطيعون فيه
جرنا وهذا ما يفعلونه الان وهذا ما بدات
بقوله ان العامل او الضلع الاستراتيجي
الاساسي لهذا نعم لهذا سوف نسال بعد
الفاصل القصير اعتذر عن مقاطعتك لاننا
مضطرين ناخذ فاصل قصير الان نعود بعد
الفاصل رصد اي مالات جديده قد تفضي اليها
هذه الحرب فلا تذهبوا
[موسيقى]
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الحلقه مما وراء الخبر انتقل الى القدس
وروني شكيت كنا نتحدث في موضوع المقاومه
وردع المقاومه الفلسطينيه يبدو ان اسرائيل
هذه المره ايضا تفاجات بان المقاومه قويه
وما زالت لديها مقدرات وما زالت تطلق
صواريخ كما حدث في الحروب الس اذا هي لم
تقضي على المقاومه كما تدعي في كل حرب
اليس
كذلك نعم لازم نفهم انه حماس في عندها قوه
حماس في عندها صواريخ اما اذا حماس بدها
تستعمل الصواريخ هدول اسرائيل تقدر ترد في
غير غير طريقها اسرائيل عندها قوه القوه
هي مش فيش موازنه قوه بين اسرائيل وبين
حماس حماس عندها القوه الضعيف وهذا القوه
تبعها هلقيت اسرائيل لسه ما استعملت كل
القوه اللي موجوده في ايدها اسرائيل لانه
لانه اسرائيل ما بدها انه يكون زي ما كان
في سنه 2008 و20 اسرائيل ما بدها انه انه
ابرياء رح يكونوا تضحيه
للحرب هذه اللي اللي موجوده هقيت هذا
السبب لمراه هذه اسرائيل عم تساوي الحرب
في غير طريقها انا بر برضه بقدر اقول انه
اسرائيل
تقدر بدون كثير مشاكل تحتال غزه بعده
ايامو شو را يصير بعدين معلش استاذ روني
فقط هذه النقطه التي ذكرتها الان تقول
اسرائيل قادره على القضاء على قدره
المقاومه على اطلاق صواريخ طالما انها
قادره على ذلك لماذا لم
تنهي المقاومه وقدرتها على اطلاق الصواريخ
في حرب 2008
و22 لانه لس لا لا لازم تفهموا شيء وشيء
لازم يفهم كل واحد يفهم غزه هي محل صغير
300 غزه محل صغير 360 كو م مربع في غزه
موجودين نقدر نقول مليون و8000 نفر اها
احن ما بدنا نسوي حرب ضد الناس ضد الشعب
في غزه هل الكل الشعب في غزه هو حماس لا
في كثير كثير كثير ناس هناك ما بدهم حماس
وبيسوي حرده حماس و وما بدهم الحرب هذه
اللي اللي حماس عم تساويه اما احنا بدنا
انه الحرب تكون ضد حماس او ضد القوه
العسكريه تبع حماس مش زي حماس زي قوه
سياسيه حماس زي قوه سياسيه رح تدل على
الارض وانا بفكر انه هذه برضه مصلحه
اسرائيليه انه حماس رح تكون تكون هناك اما
تكون قويه وتمنع الارهاب وتمنع انه تطلع
من من غزه صاروخ واحد ما يطلع من غزه هذا
اهم من كل شيء واذا اذا راح يصير الشيء
هذا ما راح يصير ولا اجتياح وما راح يصير
ولا مشاكل وانا بفكر
اسرائيل والفلسطينين في غزه بقدروا يعيشوا
بدون اتلاك النار بغير
طريقه الشيء
المهمان اسباب مش للمستوطنين مش للحكومه
ومش لغير شي طيب اخذت وقتك شكرا لك سعيد
عريقات في واشنطن هل يمكن لهذا التصيد
الاسرائيلي ان يفضي الى صياغه جديده لمشهد
ما بين اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين لا اعتقد انا اعتقد ان
اسرائيل ترى الفلسطينيين كغريق ولا تريد
ان تتوصل الى اي سلام معهم هي باستمرار
تحاول ان يكون هناك معادلات على الارض
تبقي من ناحيه على الصراع بشكل مستمر
لانها هكذا ترى مبرر وجودها ومن ناحيه
اخرى تبقي على الفلسطيني ضعفاء وغير
قادرين على تحقيق انجازات سياسيه انا
بالمناسبه ضد سياسه الصواريخ لانه لا
اعتقد ان هذه الصواريخ جلبت
الفلسطينيين اقرب الى الاستقلال واقرب الى
الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله وتعطي اسرائيل
رائع باستمرار كي تدمر وتقتل
اي المواطن الفلسطيني العادي العازل من من
السلاح انا استغرب ان ضيفك من القدس يتشدق
بالقدره الاسرائيليه العسكريه الكل يعرف
ان اسرائيل قويه عسكريا واسرائيل تستطيع
ان تؤذي الشعب الفلسطيني وتمارس هذا
الاذاء بشكل مستمر انا اعتقد ان مفهوم
المقاومه لدى الفلسطينيين يجب ان يتغير
بمعنى ان يكون هناك اولا موقف فلسطيني
واحد موقف شعبي
واحد اتخاذ مبادئ مقاومه سلميه حقيقيه حتى
ينهي هذا الاحتلال القدر الذي استمر دكتور
حسام زملط اسرائيل اقوى عسكريا وهذا امر
واقع وموجود لديها ما يجعلها قادره على
يعني كل كل سيناريوهات مفتوحه الان امامها
هل يمكن يعني ما اقصى ما يمكن ان تصل في
اليه نتحدث عن سيناريوهات مستقبليه هل
يمكن ان تعود الى اجتياح غزه مثلا ما الذي
يمكن ان
يحدث منذ ان قامت
اسرائيل وهي تخوض الحرب العسكريه تلو
الاخرى وفي كل معركه العسكريه تكسب
اسرائيل ولكنها في تقديري خسرت الحرب
فهناك فرق بين المعركه والحرب النهائيه
نحن الاقوى فلسطينيا في الساحه السياسيه
نحن الاقوى فلسطينيا في الساحه القانونيه
نحن الاقوى في الساحه الاخلاقيه وهذا
تراكم اجيال من النضال والصمود لهذا الشعب
العظيم الذي رايتموه في القدس ورايت اموه
في سخنين والناصره ورام الله ونابلس
والخليل والشتات وكل مكان هذا الشعب شعب
له حق وسيطالب به هذا الشعب خاض مراحل
كثيره منها مراحل كفاح عسكري في الخمسينات
والستينات بداته الثوره الفلسطينيه وحراكه
فتح واليوم كما قال ضيفك من واشنطن السيد
سعيد اليوم هناك شبه اجماع او اغلبيه
فلسطينيه على ضروره تبني خيار المقاومه
الشعبيه السلميه حتى نحيد اله اسرائيل
العسكريه وهذا بالضبط ما يحصل من قبل
اسرائيل شدنا وجدنا مره اخرى الى الساحه
السياسيه الاهم في هذا الامر اننا اليوم
ننظر الى الحكومه فطين
وطي حول موضوع المقاو حتى يا اختي حتى
حر هناك هناك اغلبيه فلسطينيه ترى في
المقاومه شعبيه تعظيم للمكاسب الفلسطينيه
وتفويت الفرص على نتنياهو وهذه الحكومه
المسعوره وامكانيه تحقيق النصر حتى ولو
تراكمي نعم وحتى حركه حماس في السنوات
السابقه صنعت هدنه واتفقت على تهدئه الوضع
وجاءت الى حكومه توافق وطني برنامجها هو
برنامج السيد الرئيس محمود عباس الذي يشمل
المقاومه الشعبيه كاساس للنضال و كاساس
للمقاومه ولكن دعني اؤكد مره اخرى هذا
يزعج نتنياهو هذا لا يريده نتنياهو لان
حكومته وهو شخصيا معني بمشروع واحد الا
وهو مشروع اسرائيل الكبرى لنتنياهو
ووزرائه بلا استثناء بما فيهم ليبرمان
وبنت لا يوجد فرق بين ال 67 وال 48 بيت
اييل التي تبعد امتار عن هنا في رام الله
هي نفس تل ابيب وبالمناسبه حتى بالمعنى
الديموغرافي ام الفحم هي نفس نابلس او
الخليل وبالتالي هذه الحكومه تريد مشروع
اسرائيل الكبرى وستمنع قيام دوله فلسطين
باي شكل
وتكتيكياً الى المساحه التي يرتاح فيها
وتكتيكياً يثبت لنتنياهو اننا شعب واحد
وحنجره واحده وقياده واحده ش شكرا الدكتور
حسام زملط استاذ العلوم السياسيه كنت معنا
من رام الله شكرا لك ونشكر ايضا ضيفي من
القدس الكاتب الصحفي روني شكيد ومن واشنطن
الكاتب الصحفي سعيد ريق شكرا لكم جميعا
وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر
لكم منطب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا